venti ragazzi benvenuti a questo video
sono poi dei oggi siate là di quel
giorno felice a folgaria ricominciare
allora ragazzi nel video di oggi vedremo
una roba molto figo e partenza poi
faremo anche una partita dove gioco ma
voglio spiegarvi in europa incredibile
ma veramente credibile che mi è successo
stamattina ha registrato ragazzi una
finale che merita di essere vista adesso
aveva convinto con voi perché l'ho
registrata stamattina mentre giocavo per
i fatti miei in realtà sulla playstation
ed è proprio questa che state per vedere
che una tattica che in realtà è stata
brevettata da un pochettino da qualche
settimana ma iniziato a utilizzarla
questa settimana fa praticamente che
cosa è successo quando sono arrivati in
finale ad hexagon che è la mia finale
preferito ormai ex a con la vinco
praticamente il 95 per cento delle volte
ho detto a me proviamo a fare una cosa
nuova premessa questa tattica si può
fare solo ed esclusivamente se in finale
ci arrivano non più di sette persone si
può fare anche con ottobre molto più
difficile da sette persone in giù la
farei perché se no non si può fare
allora quando si arriva ad hexagone
siete in sette
l'obiettivo è questo poi partite e non
saltate sulle piattaforme bensì cennate
dentro c'era voci sfondate tutte le
celle vedete che sta facendo questa cosa
qua mi sono creato soprattutto non so
qual è l'ultima piattaforma quindi un
pochettino mi tengo ok sono arrivato
all'ultimo
una volta arrivato direttamente
all'ultima piattaforma cosa si fa si
gira attorno al centro della mappa
creando questo buco pazzesco diventa
sempre più grande come potete vedere
tanto io l'ho fatto anche marino nel
senso che bisogna farlo in modo regolare
perché una parte più scavata e l'altra
un po meno
poi mi sono ripreso con questo punto qua
l'obiettivo è quello di girare intorno a
questo buco credito
rendendolo sempre più grande anche
magari colpendo due celle allo stesso
nello stesso momento come sempre farà
adesso vedete che nel colpiscono una
sistema ha detto in modo tale da
allargare il buco più velocemente
questo perché i ragazzi arriva alla fine
del livello quindi quando tutti gli
altri si fanno le piattaforme di sopra
arriva la fine del livello che loro non
hanno più una piattaforma di sotto e
cascano come delle pere cotte e vincete
poi è veramente assurda questa cosa
veniva com'è possibile ora è possibile è
possibile a fare sta cosa ragazzi perché
l'ho anche fatta marino perché è stata
la prima volta che l'ho fatta avere che
ho lasciato delle delle celle in mezzo
che va beh non è che uno si salva con
quelle tanto poi cadono subito però per
farlo per bene bisognerebbe evitare di
fare questa cosa vedete che il caduto
già un tizio se questo è secondo cade la
gente perché io ho tolto già l'ultima
piattaforma ho capite quindi si può fare
questa cosa ragazzi quindi l'obiettivo è
cercare toglie il più possibile rete che
cadono tutti derivato 1 rimasto solo uno
e dal fatto che ne è rimasto uno può
iniziato a saltellare a farla lentamente
perché questo qua non sapevo quanto
fosse sopra
ok quindi per non rischiare ho iniziato
a saltellare pian piano tanto è quasi
tutto distrutto anche se vuoi cade
dall'altra parte io ho la parte più
sviluppata invece è caduto giù e ho
vinto io ragazzi questo caso è stata
incredibile
tra l'altro è stata la prima volta che
ho adottato questa tattica male che
diceva ci hai provato foto di volte
finalmente ci sei riuscito al nord ma
non è andata così ragazzi ci ho provato
una volta sola
ve lo giuro ho detto no vabbè voglio
parlare è stata antica vedere che cosa
che cosa comporta
ha vinto incredibile è stata la prima
volta che ho provato a prima volta che
ho vinto
ricordatevi se volete fare questa cosa
ragazzi bisogna essere almeno allora
vero non più di sette persone 8 secondo
me è già tanto 8 e tanto almeno sette
voi compresi perché se ce ne sono tante
che cosa succede succede che arrivano di
sotto più velocemente
e se arrivano di sotto più velocemente
che non solo mi mandano a monte il piano
ma li ammazzano pure perché voi non
avete niente 18 allo ragazzi partiamo
per la partita di oggi questa è la mia
schiena attuale non ridono e si chiama
che terrò both robot che vi pare che ho
comprato l'altro ieri perché ho visto
che è uscita sul suo store nella mia
skin del pci in genere io su pc gioco in
live non ci gioco durante i video
proprio questo evento mi ritrovavo a
commentarli quella roba lì quindi per
questa volta il gameplay che vedete non
è dalla playstation mai dal pc l'altro
ragazzi non ho capito a questa roba ve
la dico anche se ormai credo si sappia
già abbastanza ma ve la spiego perché
alcuni magari non sanno indoor d'ascia
alla fine la porta più bassa e quella
che si apre la porta più bassa in questo
caso è quella sinistra
l'avete via sinistra perché che sarà la
mia destra adesso che parto perché le
porte che si aprono sono sempre
leggermente più basse questo ve lo dico
lo sa bene magari magari non lo sapete
se non lo sapete adesso lo sapete se non
lo sai salmo volevo dire ragazzi che
appunto questa skin del robot è molto
strana perché non ho capito è stato e
l'ho presa full non come si straccioni
che si chiama solo la parte di sopra
maledetti accattoni sia tutta la skin
non una parte sola poi andati in giro
che simili cucci e poi è delle skin le
prendete a metà con dio prima
aspettativa dove descrive prima ti prego
no che peccato perché l'ultima sapremo
qual era qualcosa di arrivo per 1 0 con
la destra
mannaggia al cacchio bari che funziona
comunque stava dicendo staskin ragazzi
molto strana perché non capiscono e
molto grossa non capisco se degli altri
mi afferrano più facile
o se è solo una impressione mia perché
comunque essendo più grosso è facile che
mi premi grammy non molto più facilmente
gli altri magari me lo sto immaginando
speriamo che non sia così vediamo quanti
ce l'hanno full perché per essere la
chiesa piano tutti dopo lo scatto non lo
posso vedere lancia nessuno full so solo
io le coroni sto gioco vinciamo solo noi
vabbè noi ce l'abbiamo noi siamo forti
noi facciamoci valere poi gli altri chi
se ne frega no lo dico ragazzi perché ci
sono dei giochi in cui la gente ha delle
skin pazzesche noi tu lo vedi dc9 questo
mi fa un mazzo così perché troppo forte
perché è una sfida incredibile che poi
alla fine non è mai così perché quelli
che hanno le skin belle sono solo quelli
che se vogliamo far vedere ma magari non
sono bravi invece il suo gioco palestina
alta e bravo per forza perché per averle
devi per forza vincere corone quindi non
c'è scampo non si può non c'è scampo
ragazzo let's go proviamo a vedere che
facciamo in diceva a hicks cage è la mia
mappa gli starting preferita nella
trabocca di lago sono falso io credo mi
abbia dato una volta di laghi che non mi
è piaciuto particolarmente writer rai
trade
ecco per quale morto tantissimo bene no
perché riesco a sbattere facilmente sui
muri ha forse perché non sono abituato
non lo so effettivamente salas crimini
affligge meno ma chi se ne frega avanti
ma chi se ne frega
chi importa dai clan ragazzi fraintende
quella che volevo fare oggi mi andava di
fare tra i clan non solo oggi
oggi is like i'm quando mi sveglio la
mattina di go latte cereali e slide
klein mettiamo una mappa di paul geisa
la mattina come colazione per le nostre
in creme bellissima che lo numero
e stata molto sottovalutata all'inizio
ma tra alla fine di questa season
quindi siamo più o meno in dirittura
d'arrivo
secondo me può essere reputata tra le
migliori tre di tutto dai secondo me
paolo ha squalificati 18 purificati alla
fine vediamo se riusciamo a fare un fall
gol voglio fare almeno un po i gol prima
che finisca la video di olio allora sono
fiducioso ragazzi per un bel firewall
però se siamo rimasti in 11 no porca
vacca niente pol bol mannaia potrà
cadere uniti di voi che è servita a
niente
farò non faremo un tip ton secondo me
vorrei fare di nuovo in hexagon in
diretta quella roba che ho fatto
all'inizio sarebbe divertente però in
undici non c'e la fifa però non ci
faccia fare una finale ti prego nella
finale adesso tipped ho infatti mai
allora facciamo un dito sperando di non
fare cacate che almeno se in finale
riesce hexagon voglio assolutamente di
provare a fare la cosa che ho fatto
prima una su una mia l'ho vinta vediamo
se scapparne l'uso due sarebbe
interessante la finale sarebbe in sei
ragazzi è un po ok noce un chip no vabbè
dai in essa conto rica mente il cheater
non dovrebbe fregare nulla
no ragazzi termale detto ma dai che
sfiga perché abbiamo beccato uccide
adesso rischia pure di perderla perché
genera arrivo proprio ultimo ultimo che
maledetto il cheater allora ragazzi
speriamo sia hexagon però se quello vola
vince perché può fare in volo tutto il
tempo mannaggia la reputo vittoria
sarebbe secondo da qualcuno tra i tanto
nuova posso vincere
maledetto schifoso di un fold ai 1 4 3 3
come osi starmi vicino puzzi fai schifo
royal plan ball perfetto ragazzi abbiamo
perso tanto ragazzino gli altri board
non la faccio da saranno 60 anni che non
mi esce stavano terribile guarda quello
già col già vola già vola né possibile
che c'è la coda speriamo non proprio lui
ma è 1433 e il citerna
vediamo chi è che la coda eccola
eccolo lo zio eccolo vieni qua fra tmo
vabbè tanto aspetto non ti preoccupare
un minuto e ben si mangia se quello qui
alla coda è finita ragazzi secondo si
accodava non lo vogliamo più maledetto
città schifo a quello che cambia
direzione che madrid
tanto io che faccio il giro di 4 maya ma
lo fa top è stata roba più non avete
visto niente
vabbè tanto è un minuto per la coda e
non serve a niente è impossibile
conoscendo spero che scenda ecco eccolo
cibeles boffo ciao grazie
complimenti bravo questo gioco è
meraviglioso grazie a gente come te
complimenti ma mai a chi li ha fatti
fiderò la loro madre che lavora in
autostrada maledetta ma come io ragazzi
sto jacob o mai più su computer vero che
ho visto mi sia piaciuto peccato perché
che vedevo di cose i ragazzi vi
ringrazio per aver visto il video
fatemi sapere se volete altre tattiche
mega di for guys dc inter fanno schifo e
pulsano e noi ci teniamo che come sempre
con noi ci mettiamo ragazzi in un
prossimo video come sempre belle ragazze
[Musica]